[Music]
trash heaps near south asian mega cities
like new delhi dhaka and lahore are
threatening the climate
the piles of garbage are contributing to
some of the world's strongest most
persistent greenhouse gas emissions
observed by satellite the landfills are
leaking methane planet wrecking gas that
is generated when organic material like
food scraps decompose in the absence of
oxygen
near india's capital new delhi the
gajapur landfill was spewing methane at
a rate of 2.17 metric tons an hour when
a satellite from a missions monitoring
firm
ghgsat passed overhead
if that emissions rate was sustained
over a year the leak would have the same
short-term climate impact as the annual
emissions from about 350 000 u.s cars
waste experts say the key to avoiding
methane emissions from dumps is to
separate organic material from other
waste before it enters a landfill one of
the simplest solutions is to compost
food scraps
that approach is working in the southern
indian state of kerala where authorities
are helping local municipalities and
villages implement decentralized solid
waste management systems that promote
composting at household levels
south korea also successfully banned
food from landfills and now recycles
more than 90 percent of its food
new technology is also being used to
separate mixed waste streams
ontario-based energia has developed a
system that functions a bit like a giant
garlic crusher with a metal piston that
squeezes out more than 90 wet organic
material the paste is then placed into
an anaerobic digester where microbes
break it down and methane is captured
as the world grapples with how to
balance shared climate goals against the
backdrop of historical emissions that
generated tremendous wealth and
prosperity for rich western countries
many developing nations are still
playing catch-up and prioritizing things
like food security and basic services
but experts say limiting the climate
impact of waste is as much about
behavior than it is access to technology
and significant progress can be made
even with limited resources
[Music]